let's go
Mr broccoli
was that a broccoli man
I looked like I thought they were just
like what other weird character can we
just throw in the quantum realm after a
while they just kind of threw whatever
stuck at a wall they're like okay uh a
fork a fork that talks uh Jeff loveness
looks over across the writer's room
table and someone's eating broccoli and
he goes oh okay yeah I'll put Kang in
this movie
but no oh my God it's like got Veggie
Tales all of a sudden I was not prepared
your religious allegory dreams have come
true
is the Quantum realm a metaphor for
Jesus Christ we want to thank Lord VPN
for sponsoring our show today more on
them in a bit welcome back to New
rockstars last week boss and I saw
quantumania and this week you all will
be seeing quantumania no more ducking
and dodging social media for leaks
everyone and I mean everyone has already
started releasing their reviews star
ratings their letterbox rankings and we
haven't done our non-spoiler review for
you yet we haven't done our new Rockstar
so today will be our non-spoiler review
of quantumania this is inside Marvel new
Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction show
and I'm Jessica Clements and here with
me is Eric Boss at Mt hello Jessica
oh it's so nice now we get to do our
review everyone's waiting on their hot
takes the opinions are mixed out there
the Rotten Tomatoes score a bit low I
think audience score will be higher
though yes
you guys have seen it I haven't seen it
so like I'm so excited to hear like your
spoiler-free review because like I I'm
dying to know I know nothing I've like I
I know like that the reviews have been
mixed but I haven't really read any
reviews because I've been sort of hiding
from all the reviews I said this for
wakanda forever and I say it again my
review
take it with a grain of salt everybody
has different opinions on movies and I
don't think I will ever sway anyone's
jurisdiction in movies because I watched
the worst movies there ever has been
I watch I watch my favorite genre is
horror do you bad horror movies can get
I love every single one of them I
wouldn't know I'm too soft on the inside
for horror movies okay so like I said
earlier boss and I will be giving you
the best non-spoiler review to hit 2023
on the new rockstars Channel because
it's the first one and when I say
non-spoiler I mean it because Mt again
my sweet sweet baby angel hasn't seen it
yet so there will be no mistakes and no
spoilers from Jerrica today that's me in
Paris
I love that so much
I was going I was about to say like Joss
and then I was like I forget that
parent's first name is Eric and not boss
Jessica
no it's like an Obama thing he has no
first name just Obama he doesn't have
that's right
be sure to check out nerdriot.shop where
you can always grab the latest and
greatest new rockstars gear our boys are
both wearing it they are always wearing
it and I'm never wearing it I'm
literally always wearing this [__]
hoodie I freaking love this the hoodie
is amazing like it just feels so nice
like I I feel like it's like a really
great material I like this movie I I
can't speak enough for the gear actually
because I love the design who created
one created by Mt himself so yes he
created the Vitruvian man right now you
can check out our newest line of Ant-Man
and the waspondomania inspired merch
show your love for size change in Heroes
of the quantum realm support our Channel
and check out all the great gear and
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com or merge nerd riot
thank you oh there's a mug there's a mom
oh yeah we Got Deep dive options too
there's like a detailed collection we've
got a deep dive mug and a deep dive
water bottle yeah
our merch partner Sheridan calls it the
vasma not and I have to stick with that
I think that's pretty great that's
pretty great I love him I love a water
bottle I dig it speak of the Deep dive
subscribe to the Deep dive that is
launching this weekend guys subscribe
ASAP so you can get that uh that good
that looks good wait do they know about
the investigations yet oh and I guess I
have dropped the word investigation a
few times I manage not to cringe while
saying it oh no okay get ready for some
investigations because they're coming
out subscribe to Deep dive today I can't
speak because I'm so excited Mt are you
ready to give us our question yes I have
questions for you guys because I have no
idea what this movie is going to be
about but you do so I'm gonna need you
guys some first give me your spoiler
free review of this movie because I
gotta know how you guys feel about this
movie okay well first of all like do you
think do you think this movie was a
solid ending to the Ant-Man Trilogy like
to start I don't think I wouldn't call
it the ending to the Ant-Man Trilogy
um I would call it like is it you know
there's such a big future I would still
say for um many of these characters
um uh yeah well I think in regards to
like okay they're only making three
movies kind of uh it comes in threes we
all know that uh guardians galaxy is
done after the third we do three Thor
gets his three everybody Iron Man gets a
three everybody gets three so if it is
officially done with this third one I
don't know if I'm satisfied with it
being the final way to end it because it
felt more like he wasn't the star of the
show it felt like everything was a start
it's kind of how I feel like they're
gonna approach armor Wars or not uh is
it no it's um uh it's uh Captain America
New World Order there's so many new
people in it so many casts and I'm like
okay so what is Captain America gonna do
what does Sam Wilson gonna do so I feel
like there's just like a lot to explore
and we see that in the trailer
um and I I it feels
like I want another movie on top of it
now Jess is totally right it like though
the feeling of seeing this movie it
feels like the beginning of something
not the end of anything like uh I mean
that is all tied in with Kang and yeah
I'm I'm being very careful on like how I
talk about this because I want to frame
your opinion going into this movie but
like until I I like I want you and
anybody watching hasn't seen the movie
yet to have like a a fair set of
expectations going into it and I think
what you're gonna find is like keep an
open mind about like what is in the
future for this franchise and all the
cool things that are being set up
because like man Kang is just so great
and Jonathan Majors is uh he plays this
role so well he there's like a broad
range of anger you see him at his like
angriest where he just loses control but
most of the movie it's what he described
as no moves wasted like he's just so
calculated about the way he shows zanger
and he could see it boiling just beneath
the surface when he's talking to people
and he's just like maintaining control
but like he's like
what I'm trying to tell you is you know
it's just so good
um
oh my God I agree with you overall and I
also think just as we remembered wakanda
forever was like the farewell package to
the face for this is the opening to
phase five so maybe that's why it feels
like there's it's a big introduction
um is because it's the introduction to
the phase five and ultimately we know it
ends with Secret Wars and Kang's Dynasty
so it's like yeah holy crap holy crap
right we know that's where it's all
going we know that's where it's all
going but um but I think Mt to answer
your initial question like I've I've
been able to see the movie twice and the
first time I saw the movie I saw it with
Jessica and I love that screening
because I mean just watching movies with
Jessica is amazing it's so much fun but
I think she and I felt similar we felt a
little mix we saw it in this press
screening room where the opinions were
clearly mixed I think that's reflecting
the Rotten Tomatoes score right now I
think we liked a lot of it but some of
it felt a little too like surrealist
Alice in wonderlandy to us like there
was some uncanny valley moments we're
just like I don't know if this is really
working for us right now
um and uh but when I saw it a second
time I just saw it with like a you know
a different group of people and like I
think they were having similar reactions
but because I was already past that
first wave of it I could just kind of
like ease back and enjoy the good things
about it and I think that's gonna be how
most people see this movie I think
they're gonna I think they're gonna
enjoy it more than the critics did
overall because it doesn't I I had very
high expectations going into this movie
and I think now that expectations have
been lowered by the Rotten Tomatoes
score I think people will go in with
like lower expectations and probably
enjoy it like so like just like you
mentioned Jonathan Major's performance
like so comparing the king that we saw
from Loki to this King that we see in
quantumania how like are we have any
similar performances or like because
it's a different variant like does he
provide like a a different performance
here they the that was honestly my and I
think this is what everyone over there
very common thing has been said for
people that have seen it for me and it's
not only because I'm obsessed with
Jonathan Majors I want to marry that man
but he is a phenomenal actor and
um they I think which is so insane I
don't think they could have got anyone
else because he is such a well-trained
actor that it wasn't it didn't feel like
he who remains from Loki and I was like
his Cadence the way he even carries
himself the demeanor because I
re-watched the finale to Loki recently
and I was like I was rewatching all of
the Disney plus series from like three
years ago and I was like he's so fun
he's genuinely like I've been here
forever I'm old I'm done so let me tell
you like grow up and get over it and
this King does not have that same energy
and I was like this is Jonathan Majors
delivering a performance of a lifetime
with the body of creed
I'm obsessed with him I'm I'm biased
though I'm hella biased I'm hella biased
when it comes and hopefully everyone
after seeing this movie will be hella
biased he is he is one of the best
actors of Our Generation I think right
now and uh he is perfectly cast as Kang
and you can see it in the theatrical
background of Jonathan Majors I I like
to compare it to Shakespeare like the
way he played he remains was like Puck
from Midsummer Night's Dream he was a a
mischievous guy who's hopping all around
that office who's like giggling through
it all he has kind of an immortal
quality to him
um whereas in this the the Kang who's
trapped in the quantum realm is like
Julius Caesar uh he's this Napoleonic
figure who's exiled on his Elba who just
feels so betrayed it's almost like uh
Julius Caesar if he was a ghost after
Brutus stabbed him in the back what kind
of monologue would Julius Caesar give
um I think that's oh yeah wow
[Laughter]
okay I'll spoil one thing he says that
in the movie he says
[Laughter]
wow
hang takes off his shoes and steps on a
Lego it sucks
pick up your damn toys
oh my God so yeah just to kind of give
you a sense of the the spectrum of
different uh Kings between
um he remains in the Kang in this movie
uh just very completely different human
beings in the way that they move like I
mean uh this King moves really just his
fingers for like the first half of the
movie Just which you know
I mean I'll leave that to your
imagination viewer
I'm sure he has a lot of practice you
know what I'm saying
just when he called me back but before
we continue guys let's we have to thank
your VPN for sponsoring this video
because have you ever gotten into a
situation where you wanted to watch one
of your favorite movies or series only
to discover that it's not currently
streaming in your country one way to get
more content options in your life is to
check out norvpn with norvpn you can
change your virtual location with just
one click which makes it easier to find
streaming platforms at a lower price and
we can even access platforms that aren't
available in the US with just one click
you can choose from over 5400 servers in
over 60 countries personally I use
nordvpn a lot when doing research for a
breakdown if I need to look at a
cinematic reference I need to have
access to tons of content that might not
be streaming in the United States but
thanks to nordvpn I can complete my
research and get you all those sweet
sweet breakdowns that you crave I like I
really love using the door VPN because
like I I like masking my IP address when
I'm like when I want to stream online or
like do whatever I'm like I need to like
not have my freaking good location shown
um it's just like a really Nifty thing
to have
um as a nerd and doing my nude things
online plus door vpn's benefits and
features go Way Beyond improving your
streaming experience you can also access
games and discounts only available in
other regions and block malware written
websites while you explore securely we
encourage you to try nordvpn for
yourself so grab your exclusive nordvpn
deal by going to nordvpn.com Marvel to
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus four additional months for
free it's completely risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee that
is
n-o-r-d-vpn.com Marvel for an exclusive
discount plus four months free you're
going to want to get a good night's
sleep before you say Ant-Man and was
quantumania ask me about it because I
needed one and here are new rockstars We
Trust our sleepy time with Helix and we
have for many many years Helix makes
premium mattresses and bedding that are
customized to fit your needs and
conveniently shipped right to your door
which Helix mattress is right for you
don't worry about it Helix made a sleep
quiz that matches your unique body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you based on your different
sleep positions and firmness preferences
they have something for everyone's
unique taste and if you sleep with a
partner you can take the Sleep quiz
together and find something that's
perfect compromise for both of you and
let me tell you I sleep alone but I have
the body of two people and let me and I
need a big soft non-switty mattress
because I sweat all the time and I love
my Helix mattress the best part about
all of this is that Helix delivers your
mattress right to your door with free
shipping in the US plus Helix has a 100
night sleep trial so you get more than
three months to make sure that you love
it or you get a full refund what other
Mattress Place does that Helix
mattresses have a 10 year warranty
that's a decade you guys and they even
offer financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away and you need it I love
my Helix and I think you would too if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix you can click the link below or go
to Helix sleep.com inside marble to get
20 off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows that's helixsleep.com inside
marble go to Turbo Tax and don't do your
taxes meet with an expert who will do
them for you Turbo Tax experts can
relieve you from the stress of taxes and
file for you so you can do not taxes
show your eyes things that are not taxes
unpack a moving Box about taxes taste
not taxes saying not tax is Lullaby hope
not taxes sleeps through the night grab
a saddle and ride on not taxes into the
sunset with Turbo Tax an expert will do
your taxes from start to finish ensuring
your taxes are done right guaranteed so
you can relax feels good to be done with
your taxes doesn't it come to Turbo Tax
and don't do your taxes visit
turbotax.com to learn more Intuit
TurboTax full service products only
video meeting while expert does your
taxes required to see guaranteed details
at turbotax.com guarantees Turbo Tax all
right guys so um I have a question here
so which MCU projects should I watch to
make me like appreciate this movie the
most in like what movie should I watch
to prepare for this one basically you
know what I was thinking yeah what you
know what I was thinking personally and
okay and maybe watch Vasa breakdown but
definitely watch my ending explain
because it'll make sense I think people
should watch Multiverse of Madness oh
yeah you know I think it's a very fun
yeah not like completely required but
think of once you see the movie Go Back
to Multiverse and Madness and then
really devour it that's mine that's mine
that's a really good pick I mean I think
um
I think Loki definitely watch
um just to have that comparison point
from he remains to this Kang I think
it's going to be extremely relevant to
watch the six episodes of Loki if you
don't have time to watch the six
episodes of Loki watch the finale of
Loki
um
from Eric yeah are you gonna switch
breakdowns yeah
breakdowns all the time when I need to
go to like a specific thing where I'm
like I don't know if I know this I go to
the exact spot on one of our breakouts
to go see if someone else I'm like and
then I credit you guys I credit you guys
Loki's probably more important than
watching Ant-Man or Ant-Man and the WASP
um because I think the way Ant-Man
there's some like interesting like
you might even be a bit more confused if
you watch Ant-Man the WASP first
especially with the character of Janet
like Jess did you feel this way there's
some stuff where it's like oh Janet why
are you mad about this now when you
weren't mad about this
I don't even don't start
but they do a good job they do a good
job making this movie work
um even for people who don't remember
Ant-Man or Ant-Man the WASP or you know
or people who hadn't seen it you know
okay that I think that's like the
interesting part is compared to a lot of
other MCU properties I don't think you
really like you said I don't think you
need to see the first and second one you
can just jump to this this one
quantumania and I think you'll be like
lost a little bit but again we don't
know anything about the quantum realm so
it's like everything that we learn or
like most of everything so a lot of what
we learn is in this movie so I think
it's like kind of a clean slate for us
yeah and you know I think this movie
absolutely explores the quantum realm
and you learn I mean you do learn about
the people of it uh quite a bit and
they're like their conflicts but they're
still about like the general nature of
the quantum realm in the history of it
is still a complete you know like but
that's I would think that's the case in
every Marvel movie like they kind of
give you a glimpse and they explore the
place with they don't give you the full
rules of anything ever it's true and I
like it because like I like when like
they give us a little something it's
like oh we'll go back to that place
later and I hope that we get back to the
quantum realm uh more in as future
movies progress because I just I think
that the place looks very visually
appealing and very I I like the like
weird vibe of everything especially the
broccoli man now that I know that exists
my god
um I need to see more broccoli people in
the MCU others
once you see what the broccoli man does
oh no one of the bro okay jeez I'm so I
don't wanna next question one of the
broccoli I think broccoli man was there
on January 6th is that what we're seeing
yeah I think he started January 6 in the
quantum room which I didn't know they
knew about oh man they marched for a
while
yeah but yeah um but yeah how many major
plot points would you say happens that
affect phase five and six in this movie
I mean I gotta watch the movie again to
really think I mean there's at least
like
what would you say there's at least like
four there's at least like four that
they're all kind of combined I mean I
don't know I would say this is pretty
big deal like these like the way this
movie ends the it's very very uh
critical the way it sets up I don't
think you can skip this one going
forward like okay there's certain MC
movies that I we at new rockstars to say
you can't skip any of them but you know
average viewers might be like ah you can
skip Black Widow right but like this one
you absolutely cannot you absolutely
yeah it definitely feels like the flash
um in that manner like this year's gonna
have like such crucial movies to both
universes
um yeah it just feels like one of those
movies that like if you want to like
enjoy Kang Dynasty or like understand
what is going on in the future of the
MCU this introduction of Kang is like
the Primo
um place to do it as far as I can tell
from just the marketing so um it makes
me happy to know that like this is like
the the official start of phase five I'm
very excited but yeah um and like how
many people would you say live in the
quantum realm if you guys could like
just do an estimated number it's got I
mean I was in the millions right I mean
we see it just when the trailers alone
there are multiple cities I don't know
do you count the quantum knots like
Kang's like soldiers do they count as
people I don't really know what they are
um living life forms
even we see
like oh that's a good point
there's a in the trailer especially it's
like you see a bunch of things this
movie redefines what a life form is
really because you'll see when you watch
it it's like oh I didn't realize that
thing was alive so there's like and the
sentience is like the animals are just
as smart as like the people are down
there so that's why I was like with the
broccoli man it's like oh it's a
broccoli that's a man
so is it a person
do they like is there like a language
Berry I don't know if this is spoiler
but like is there like a language
barrier between like the human people
and the people of the quantum realm or
do people just speak English
automatically
um yeah I don't want to say
um but I will say like thematically to
this movie communication is a is an
interesting theme in this movie
um both to like where Scotland Begins
the story and like his journey into the
quantum realm like I think communication
if I could sum up the theme of this
movie it's communication because one of
my favorite um deleted scenes from
Ant-Man 2 is like this when Janet is
like talking to this weird Quantum
creature with her like voice chain like
she it's like a translator that
translates to the weird lorbon Quantum
realm language and I was like wow that's
super neat like I wonder like if that's
gonna factor into this next movie like
if there's a language barrier there
um so yeah I mean here's one thing like
I don't want to be uh too negative on
this movie I think the Rotten Tomato
critics are already doing a good enough
job at that but I think going to this
movie expecting something that's pretty
silly it is like imagine the first time
you saw the Wizard of Oz and how silly
it is when Dorothy goes to eyes he got
talking trees you got a yellow brick
road there's a witch trying to kill you
there's a scarecrow that talks they all
sing the same song with different verses
again and again and again it's wild they
go to a Emerald City where they all get
like polished and the horses change
colors that's kind of what the feeling
is here it's like it's also very Alice
in Wonderland and it's surreal it's
meant to be surreal so like if you go
with that expectation and then you just
kind of can let go of things that you
might normally cringe at I think you
might really enjoy this movie
um I think the humor is really great I
think it lives up to the to the jokes of
uh of the first two Ant-Man movies the
gags are really great uh the dialogue's
super funny I think what it misses from
the first two anime movies is that kind
of small scale madcap energy that I
really liked at the first Suite movies
it was just they took place in San
Francisco and they're just kind of
running around and I like that and I and
I kind of miss it this movie does not
have that this movie's way more epic
than that like that that is a little bit
of a bummer because like I did like you
said like I love that like the x-con
team and like the like them doing the
heist and stuff like on like uh the
normal human plane like that that's
super great but I also like you again
like you pointed out I love weird [__]
like weird [__] is my bread and butter I
like like cool visuals and like and at
the end of the day Ant-Man films are
like basically astronaut films um where
they just like travel to different
places and like this is like the
ultimate end goal that we've been teased
at since the first and the first Ant-Man
film of this Quantum realm so like
getting the journey there and like see
what's Below in the basement of the MCU
essentially is so super exciting to me
like so I am very
um very very amped to just analyze the
quantum realm up and down I already want
this movie on Disney plus like already
just put it on Disney plus already I
need it on Disney plus you're gonna have
to wait eight months
eight to nine months like a baby you
guys um
um I think I'm too afraid of also
spoiling more to this movie I think
we're gonna cap it there for the review
of Ant-Man and was quantumania that's it
for this episode of inside Marvel
reminder to subscribe to the Deep dive
Channel at Deep dive new rockstars Deep
dive NR look at those little monkeys
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow Eric EA Vos follow Mt at
mastertonment describe it inside Marvel
wherever you get your podcast thanks for
watching but I think I think I think we
have something I think we have a little
preview of something oh a little preview
oh a little preview is it the Deep dive
commercial
hey y'all
[Applause]
in vast motives
hi I'm Eric Boss and this is new
rockstars the Deep dive in which I go
beyond hunting Easter eggs to try to
decode what the eggs mean is this Kang
variant truly surprised here or is he
performing a script that requires him to
act surprised
[Music]
foreign